it's great to welcome to the program
today david shore who's a data scientist
who consults with democratic groups and
has
a number of insights into many different
areas
of uh the political world is is the way
i say it uh glad glad to have you here
today a pleasure to be here
so let's just start with 2020 polling i
mean there the
how how off or on was it
certainly joe biden was winning the
popular vote polling
and he won the popular vote and he
became the president there were
certainly some states in which the
numbers
leading up to the election did not quite
work out i mean
what's your sort of overall assessment
of what's happening with polling right
now
yeah well first i as as a i guess
disclaimer i think in some ways it's
funny that going into election night
we thought that joe biden would win and
the democrats would get 50 or 51 senate
seats and
you know the end result joe biden is
president democrats do have 50 senate
seats
uh so i think that is kind of funny but
you know that said
the polling was actually fairly bad
this year you know just to put numbers
on it uh i think there's kind of two
distinct problems you know with polling
you know one
is just that uh we really
the numbers were way too high for
democrats uh on average there was about
a three percent
uh bias toward democrats and that's in
vote share which means that in terms of
margin you're looking at you know
roughly six percent
this happened on basically every level
of government on the senate on the house
you know and the presidency and you know
if you were looking at polls
you would experience coming in expecting
that biden was going to win states like
florida
that we would have you know maybe like a
bunch of democratic seats and that we
were supposed to pick up 10 seats in the
house
and you know none of those things
happened and then i think on top of that
you know it's not just that the polling
on average you know was
uh was too democratic but the kind of
uh error pattern by state you know
really matched what we saw in 2016 and
you know what we saw
in 2018 where these kind these states in
the midwest
with a lot of you know non-college
educated whites uh
really uh we saw a strong overestimation
of support i think there was a
you know a canopy act poll or uh in
wisconsin right before the election
where
it said that biden would win by 15 and
he ended up you know winning by less
than one
uh so yeah i think it was a pretty bad
cycle for polling and then
just the last angle just to recount you
know all the ways the polls were bad
this year
is just in terms of looking at
coalitions you know the big
changes in this election roughly
speaking were that non-college whites
were you know basically where they were
in 2016
college educated whites swung something
like six or seven percent toward us
you know african americans swung two
points uh down and i think hispanic
voters you know now that all the data's
in looks like they dropped by like nine
percent
and the polls didn't really see any of
those trends coming there was like a
little bit
of warning signs you know with non-white
voters though it ended up being worse
than the polls thought
but if you looked at the polls the polls
really told this story that we were
going to see education depolarization
that non-college whites were going to
trend toward democrats and college
educated and dwight's we're going to you
know stay
basically where they were last time and
that just didn't happen you know if you
look at
uh if you just look at the college
non-college gap it looks like the polls
were off by something like 10 or 11
percent which is
crazy um in a lot of ways the polls were
a lot worse than 2016.
so let's dig into one aspect of this
which is that the concept of polling is
you can't pull everybody so the idea is
you get a representative sample and what
does it mean that it's representative
often we're talking about well
we'll normalize it for education or we
can normalize it for race we can
normalize it for political affiliation
you can normalize it for age all of
these different things
but one of the things you really can't
normalize for correct me if i'm wrong
is the types of people that are more
likely to participate in a poll
versus the types of people that are more
likely to opt out and
we heard this from some on the right who
who kind of said it as
uh a lot of trumpists don't trust
the polls so they either give
deliberately fake answers or don't
participate
and there's no great way to deal with
that as a pollster
how much truth is there to the general
idea of
people willing to and not willing to
participate and then maybe more
specifically to some of the explanations
that were given by
supporters of the pres of former
president trump
yeah i think in some ways i think
there's something to the story i do want
to be clear that
if you ask someone who they're going to
vote for in a survey they do generally
tell you the truth
because it's not an issue with trolling
but you know that said
i think one of the big drivers for why
the polling was so wrong this year and
why it was actually worse than 2016
was that there were really giant you
know differences in who was answering
uh the phone you know something that you
know the way that uh you know the firm i
worked for the way that they do polling
they actually match people back to uh
voter files and so we can see their
party registration and something that
was really clear
is that starting around march democrats
became much more likely you know to
answer the phone than republicans and i
think it's it's kind
they kind of stayed at these elevated
levels throughout the entire election
and i think there's a pretty clear story
that this had a lot to do with lockdown
that democrats were literally home
there's like a lot of cell phone
mobility data that really shows that
democrats stayed home and they didn't
really have much to do and they started
answering surveys at high rates
and republicans weren't doing that and
you know they just weren't
uh picking up the phones but you know
generalizing you know that was an issue
with this year and i i think it was uh
clear
um but even in 2016 you know when we
look back
at why the polls were wrong and i think
this bias continued now like why is it
that pollsters have such a hard time
measuring opinion in states that have a
lot of working-class white people
and originally people really talked
about this
in terms of trump turning out a lot of
new voters and i think that there's a
lot of evidence now that that's not
really true that
you know all of these election switches
were really driven by people changing
their minds as opposed to changes and
who voted
but then the question is why did why
were the polls wrong
and why were the polls wrong in
more in working class areas and it kind
of comes back to this concept
of social trust that political
scientists and
sociologists like to talk about and so
that's just operationalized with this
question of do you think that people can
be trusted or do you think that people
should
keep to themselves and something that's
pretty wild just socially is that you
know the government's been asking this
on a very high quality survey they spend
a couple thousand dollars per person and
they get like a 70
response rate phone response rates are
closer to one percent you know just for
reference point
and they've been asking it since the the
670s and it used to be that you know
roughly 55 percent of people
said that people could be trusted and
that figure is down to 30 percent
so that's sociologically that's
sociologically very concerning
though above my pay grade but it has
measurement implications
uh because people who trust um
people who say that people can be
trusted kind of unsurprisingly are a lot
more likely to answer phone surveys
and that used to not matter very much
because
how much you trusted the people around
you and how much you trust institutions
just used to not be that correlated with
partisanship
uh but in 2016 you know donald trump
really reshaped the coalition
uh you know if 2012 was a coal it was a
basically
uh you know a fight over whether or not
we should have universal health care
2016 was much more of a referendum on
like how much do you trust the people
around you
and we were only talking in these
surveys to these high trust people who
say that people can be trusted
and if you and you know there was
literally this hidden
you know hidden majority of low trust
folks who
went in the other direction and so you
know we've actually looked in crosstalk
and if you look
among people who said that people could
be trusted that group swung toward
democrats by
you know something like four or five
percent but the other group went
completely in the opposite direction
and you know this high trust sample that
was the people we were pulling and
that's the world we expected to see on
election
day but then they didn't actually answer
and
you know the same thing you know i
actually you know people don't realize
happened in 2018 democrats won so they
didn't notice but if you look at the
actual margins in places like
west virginia places like michigan
places like ohio
the elections were much closer than
people than you know the polls
originally thought
even if uh even if we ended up winning
and then we see the same thing again you
know in uh in 2020
uh and i and i think that uh social
trust is a very important you know angle
for understanding it
one of the things i saw you to shift
gears a little bit i i read some of your
tweets about which i find very
interesting is about the bias of the
electoral college
and you posted a couple things that i
find really interesting one is that you
you posted the partisan bias of the
electoral college over time and one of
the things you found is that
democrats now need about 52 percent of
the vote in order to have a 50 50
shot of winning the presidency given
that it's not the national popular vote
that decides but but rather the
electoral vote
and then the other really interesting
thing is that
there's this notion that part of what
makes the electoral college
depart in terms of its orientation from
the popular vote
is that small states are really
overweighted relative to their
populations and you pointed out
something very interesting which is that
in terms of the difference makers when
it comes down to who ultimately wins the
electoral college
it's more about the fact that there are
some larger population states
which are relatively close could be 52
48 could be 55 45 60 40
but because they are winner take all you
are essentially
i don't know if the right word is
disenfranchising but if you're part of
the 42 percent of democrats in a big red
state
your vote essentially doesn't matter for
calculating the electoral college
can you talk a little bit about that
yeah absolutely uh i i think it's just
important to
you know say that the bias in the
electoral college i think
is very new you know it is true that you
know gore won the popular vote and
lost the electoral college but the bias
of the electoral college was really
quite small that year
you know uh gore got something like
fifty twenty-two percent
and and you know uh he very very very
narrowly lost
um and so that you know that was like
random and not really that big a deal
and really the electoral college at
various points is favored democrats you
know it's if
uh if barack obama in 2012 had gotten
about 49.5 percent of the vote
he actually still you know probably
would have won that's that's why people
talk about the blue wall there
there are basically these big this is
just a little bit of a history lesson
but you know they're
they're just these big midwestern states
that
kind of had their economies centered
around farming and manufacturing and as
a result
you know they have rel they're both you
know relatively white and also have
relatively low education levels relative
to the rest of the country
and the electoral college really comes
down to who does well in these places
and in 2012 you know obama a lot of his
appeal was he actually did very well you
know with midwestern
whites he did better in the midwest than
carrie and really than a lot of
democrats before him
uh and but he also did well enough among
college-educated whites to make places
like virginia and colorado competitive
so the electoral college had like a
small bias in his favor
2016 totally changed that though and
you know it's really great if you can
see the graph because you know just kind
of wiggles around zero and then there's
just this sudden plunge
um to there being i think a three point
uh you know a three-point gap
uh bias in in the republican favor and i
think that that's
you know the really under-appreciated
part of understanding 2016
which is that barack obama got about 52
of the two-party vote uh in 2012
and hillary clinton got 51.1
of the vote and in any other democracy
that would have been fine
you know a 0.9 percent decline still you
know comfortably above 50.
um but the problem was that the
electoral college shifted from being
about half a point bias in favor of
democrats
to being three points biased in favor of
republicans and then that bias
increased again uh and so it's
helpful to put numbers on these things
and you know just to get to your other
question i think people really don't
understand why the electoral college
causes this bias you know as you said
it's not that you have these
tiny states it's not about wyoming in
order to get to 270
states you have to win states like
wisconsin like minnesota
like ohio and there just happened to be
a bunch of relatively evenly divided
states that right now are somewhat more
republican
than the country overall and i think the
you know the key
point is that the reason why this
happened is because democrats have
started doing so much worse
uh among working-class white people and
you know unless that gets reversed i
think it's unlikely that this is gonna
that this is gonna revert you know i
think a lot of people
expected that you know things would get
better this year and the key point is
that
the bias went from three points in 2016
to four points in 2020
and so it really just shows how
unworkable you know our coalition is
under this set of rules
uh absolutely in fundamental insights to
understand really
in thinking about future elections i
mean if you if one does not understand
reality as it is it's hard to run a
campaign that that is based on that
reality
uh we've been speaking with david shore
who's a data scientist who consults with
democratic groups
you certainly should follow him on
twitter as i do david i i so appreciate
your time today
oh thank you so much a pleasure to be
here